-Our first guest tonight
is CNN's
chief Washington correspondent
He hosts "The Lead"
weekday afternoons,
as well as the network's Sunda
show, "State of the Union.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend, Jake Tapper.
How are you, Jake?
-Hey, Seth.
How you doing, buddy?
-Good.
So, we talked many times -
you were on the show many time
as a guest during the Trump era.
This is your first time during
the Biden presidency.
How have things changed
for you so far?
-Well, it's, uh...
We're still dealing with thing
that Trump left in his wake.
Right?
The failures of his presidency
The pandemic's still
raging out of control,
although there's a light
at the end of the tunnel
with the vaccines,
and then of course,
the January 6th insurrection
the MAGA terrorist attack.
So, I wouldn't say
it's over yet,
and, you know,
we also have his legacy,
what he's done
to a once-great political party,
the Republican Party, where,
now a bunch of them think
that lying and indecency
is the ticket to success.
So, he's gone, and I'm not -
you know, I don't have
to pick up my phone
and read tweets
with the same kind
of level of dread
that I used to have to before,
but he's still --
his presence
is very much with us.
You know, it's like --
What did they say?
You know, "Would you rathe
fight one horse-sized duck
or 10 duck-sized horses?"
-Yeah.
-So, we're now fighting --
It's 10 duck-sized horses
is what we're dealing with
-That's a Churchill quote,
right?
I know you're --
[ Both laugh ]
-Sadie Churchill, yes.
-You've often pointed out
the fact that you become
less popular
based on which party's president
is currently in office.
You have been critical
of President Biden,
specifically, you know --
one of the things is
his failure to mention
any punishment to Saudi Arabia
for the murder of the journalist
Jamal Khashoggi.
Why is it important
that President Biden has chose
not to take any steps afte
this report that was released?
-Well, he -- I mean,
the main issue here is tha
he let the Crown Prince,
Mohammed bin Salman,
off the hook.
There's no punishment
for him at all,
even though
the Biden administration,
as opposed
to the Trump administration,
disclosed and revealed
an unclassified statement
revealing that
the intelligence community
thinks that MBS had this
"Washington Post" journalist
Jamal Khashoggi,
who lived in Virginia --
had him killed.
And Biden, as a candidate,
and most of his cabinet
and his administration faulted
Trump for not doing it.
And, you know,
in the Bob Woodward book -
I forget if it was
"Fear" or "Rage," or, you know
whatever -- whichever, "Fury."
In the Bob Woodward book,
Trump says about MBS,
"I saved his ass,"
because Congress wanted
to go after him and punish him
for the murder
of this journalist,
that he ordered.
Biden's basically saying,
"Look, I -- I can't."
He knows the relationship with
Saudi Arabia is too important.
Okay, so the words are
different, but either way,
MBS's ass has been saved
by two presidents in a row
So, I mean, look,
either a president stands up
to a world leader ordering
the murder of a journalist
a "Washington Post" journalist
or he doesn't.
I just don't see much
of a difference
in terms of the result.
-What about
the reaction to reporting?
Is it any different?
Because, obviously,
any administration
is going to take issue
with the way they're covered
Have you felt
the same level of pushback
from the Biden administration,
or is it different?
-Not from the administration
I think that
they're professionals.
I mean, I think
that Secretary of State
Antony Blinken, for example --
I think that he understand
the role of journalists,
and I think that he's not
gonna personally attack me
or President Biden's
not gonna personally attack me
I certainly don't fear
that Biden's gonna, you know
send me some mean tweets.
I mean, I think they're adults
That doesn't mean
I'm not gonna criticize them
or their actions
when I think it's called for
Now, the left on social media --
Democrats on social media --
are, you know,
outspoken in their views
of me criticizing either
Biden or Governor Cuomo.
They don't like it,
and I've been told that
some of them
are gonna unfollow me,
because they -- you know,
I guess they liked
what I did before,
they don't like it now.
It's okay.
I mean, like I've said,
I've been through this
a few times now.
You know,
for eight years under Obama,
I was a neoconservative
right-wing hack.
Then I was a Trump-hater.
I mean,
so it's just part of the job
-You contain multitudes.
I've always said that about you.
-[ Laughs ]
-I want to ask you --
-Now, that's Winston Churchill
-[ Laughing ]
Yeah, there you go.